- That's Buddhist belief.
Treat others as you would
like to treat your mother.
I believe in that stuff.
Whatever religion or genre,
practice or thesis
believes in doing
the right thing
and doing right by others
and then the universe takes over
and brings you value.
I actually think it's not some
karma cosmic thing,
I think it's actually
quite practical.
Would it not make sense to our
practical brains that if you're
doing something
good for somebody else
that that puts you
in a leverage position
for something good
to happen to you.
I'm actually not very romantic
or cosmic or spacey
or Zen-ified around
providing people value.
I love karma,
I believe in it 'cause
I believe karma's
fucking practical.
(laughs) How about that?
Because I believe
karma's practical.
I believe that if you do
something good
for somebody else,
if you provide them value,
if you're taking their time and
providing them
with good thoughts
and good themes
and good strategies
and good outlooks
and seeing white space,
I believe that the
people that started
Snapchat design agencies,
building filters,
oh, it broke out.
I believe that the people that
went out and built Snapchat
design filter agencies
that have been making
money over the last month
because they listened to me,
yeah, I believe that they'll
say good things about me
that will make more
people pay attention.
I believe that they'll tell
clients to work with me.
I believe that they'll
tell their sister
that's talented or
their brother that's talented
to go work for
Vayner or intern there.
Yes, I do believe that doing
the right thing is practical.